You have one new ride request
Hum... Hey! You're my ride, of course!
start the meter
Sorry what's to history
before I picked you up
like... I had my first fare of the night
who was this girl
My friends  and I would just grab a couple of drinks here if you wanna come in for a round
I've got a drive
what are you doing here with me?
Get in there and bring back a beautiful woman
Hi! Wow, you finally came!
sometimes when you trust your impulses
incredible things can happen
This is your friend?
Hi! Hi!
stranger is just a friend that you haven´t met yet
we´re all beautiful weirdos
run and jump into my arms
If it were a movie, sprinkles will come on right now
and he would kiss you under the fake rain of L.A
I´ll give you some cash. james do you mind going in for me
I prefer if you did it bro
Look, if you show them this, they´ll give you
anything you want
Tell me that does not real.
If you don´t, your new friend in the back´s night
It´s going to take a slait turn to the worst
You're ready brother?
wait, wait, wait.
I need you to listen, please.
I need you to call the police
we´re conditions to do what was expected
But tonight, you get to do other ones
We're gonna need pain killers
Please, just stop.
Looks like you get some shops left to do
I know that it isn't some game
Why are you really doing this?
Something, something,desperect times
Something, something, desperect measures
I'm really sorry
It's ok
You have reach
your destination